do you think there'll ever be a uh
community reunion because they're doing
all these other shows
uh if you had asked me that a year ago i
would have said yes
but no and uh i would have said like who
knows
but we did a table read a year ago and
it was so much fun
and donald came so it was great and then
uh pedro pascal played this part in the
in a table read and i like i burst out
crying with my wife afterwards because i
was just like i missed all those people
so much i mean just crying and i was i
couldn't keep it in and uh
so i think now more than ever it's
possible
uh but as you know uh you need like
millions of dollars you need schedules
to line up you need
scripts i think you need the head of the
whole operation to go i just
love that show yeah maybe right
you need you need like if you're
building an aircraft carrier
there's a lot of parts that go in and
yeah you need an admiral to go like
let's make it
and uh uh so i would say it's
it's more likely now than it was it's
more likely
well than it was a year ago okay right
all right
uh but i uh you know again if someone
out there
has a like i don't know 40 million
dollars
guys come on you want to see a community
reunion 40 mil
that's that's the mugs are seven people
99 if you're there's a couple of hedge
fund guys listening right